- We are back.
And it's great that this
show can be a vehicle
for up and coming musicians
to gain a wider audience,
'cause I love doing that.
So these next guests are
incredible vocalists on their own,
and together, their sounds
blend into something whimsical
and truly soulful.
And this is so cool, their
sophomore album, "Silver",
was recorded old school to
tape, which is super rad.
Now performing "Never Say Never",
give it up for say Say She She.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(upbeat music)
♪ Sometimes takes a minute
'fore we really find it ♪
♪ Will you make a move to
take this love and bind it ♪
♪ You ♪
♪ Choose ♪
♪ When it takes a turn
with changes in affection ♪
♪ Flip it on its head and
take a new direction ♪
♪ Choose ♪
♪ You ♪
♪ When I'm wishing and waiting
for all the wrong things ♪
♪ And I'm wanting you to notice ♪
♪ It's a risk I'm
suddenly willing to take ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm hoping
that you will show it ♪
♪ Are we ever together ♪
♪ Do we even remember
nothing lasts forever ♪
♪ But we never say never ♪
♪ No, we never say never ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ Naked as a day, come
lay a new foundation ♪
♪ Needing all the clay
for molding innovation ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ For you ♪
♪ Carving out the time
to make a fun decision ♪
♪ Push it to the edge
and play a new position ♪
♪ Do ♪
♪ What's true ♪
♪ Been believing since
the day that we met ♪
♪ I am leaving all behind ♪
♪ It's a risk I'm
suddenly willing to take ♪
♪ I will see you down the line ♪
♪ Are we ever together ♪
♪ Do we even remember
nothing lasts forever ♪
♪ But we never say never ♪
♪ No, we never say never ♪
♪ No, we never say ♪
♪ Sometimes takes a minute
'fore we really find it ♪
♪ No, we never, never ♪
♪ No, we never say never ♪
♪ Never say ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ Never say never ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, y'all.
All right, once more, let's
hear it for Say She She.
Their new album, "Silver", is out now.
We'll be right back in a moment.